un vestido de traje oscuro y con gesto
sombrío carlos tercero llegó al palacio
de buckingham acompañado de su esposa
camila reina consorte la pareja fue
recibida por cientos de personas y el
nuevo monarca aprovechó la ocasión para
mostrar cercanía y amabilidad hacia los
admiradores que esperaban su llegada
desde escocia
se mostró muy abierto y agradecido de
que la gente viniera y parecía contento
de estar aquí y aprecio que la gente
estuviera twitter
al ingresar en el palacio londinense el
rey mantuvo su primera reunión con la
primera ministra británica y liz tras
posterior al encuentro el decimotercer
monarca de reino unido se dirigió a la
nación en el mensaje televisado
agradeció el apoyo mostrado en un
momento difícil y por supuesto recordó a
su madre
me dirijo a ustedes hoy con sentimientos
de profundo dolor a lo largo de su vida
su majestad la reina mi querida madre
fue una inspiración y un ejemplo para mí
y para toda mi familia y tenemos con
ella la deuda más sentida que cualquier
familia puede tener con su madre por su
amor su afecto su guía su comprensión y
su ejemplo
cairns
understanding and dixon
dejó en claro que su vida ya no será la
misma
ya no será posible dedicarle tanto
tiempo y energía a las organizaciones
benéficas ya los temas que tanto me
interesan pero sé que esta importante
labor continuará en manos de otros
carlos tercero otorgó los títulos de
príncipe y princesa de gales a su
primogénito william y su nuera kate
expresó su amor por su hijo menor harry
y su esposa megan un gesto significativo
hacia una pareja cuyas relaciones con el
resto de la familia han sido tensas
entretanto el féretro de isabel reposa
en el salón de baile de su residencia de
balmoral en escocia y viajará hasta
londres para ser velada homenajeada y
enterrada